listen if you had a company that has
been valued at fifty billion dollars
then they put up bows on the back to
your head and they put a bull's-eye on
the back of your industry's head yeah
it could not be fun sometimes
on the hood of every yellow taxi in New
York City is a small blue and white
plate called a medallion
this is basically a license to operate a
cab and Jean Freedman is known as the
taxi came because he operates more cars
in New York City than anyone else
roughly a thousand of them
my first two medallions were maybe 150
thousand apiece in the late 90s when
people just didn't want to be in this
business the prices I think got up to
about 1.3 million for corporate
medallion at one point
to those of you keeping score that's an
almost 800 percent gain for Jean he was
good to be in the taxi game
but recently a black cloud has formed
over the industry in 2014
uber more than doubled its footprint in
New York City and since then the average
price of a medallion has shrunk to about
eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
I think uber is a brilliant fascinating
you know technology company I think
they're good taxi company I think
they're giving limo company I don't
think that they're a good employer I
don't think they're honorable the way
that they do politics or they would
conduct themselves river is
circumventing regulation there's a rule
book that's 200 pages right you know
just for middle Italian owners that we
have to follow everything from what the
meter looks like how you're supposed to
work what you're supposed to charge if
the regulations that we're out there
right now we're enforced that would be
fine
I'm the operator I'm the operator
nobody's going to operate better than me
and definitely not somebody sitting in
Silicon Valley is going to know what's
better for my passengers my drivers me
and the regulator right better than me
as much as you BRR has changed the taxi
industry it's only one of jeans problems
he borrowed heavily to expand his fleet
and in March
Citibank moved to foreclose on 90 of his
medallions claiming over 30 million
dollars in unpaid loans he was able to
reach a settlement on half of those for
22 of his companies which represent the
other half still had to declare
bankruptcy myself guys we have a
liquidity problem with liquidity issue
I'm going reorganization on about 22 of
my companies we need to change is there
a universal app is there proper
regulation whatever strategy overhaul
Jean can manage he'll have to do it
quickly over the last two years
taxi pickups have dropped from 14
million to 12 million per month I like a
challenge since last summer I ripped
everything up and I'm rebuilding it from
scratch that's really exciting
I'm 44 I'm on honorary millennium well
okay just have long hair now for the air
you know like a dress a little bit like
caper and cooler and I think a lot
differently I'm thinking about what can
I do
I always bragged that my business times
are either awesome
excellent or just very good so I think
we're on the bottom of very good right
now